i was in high school my volleyball team  had a sleepover we decided it would be  fun as a joke to tp our own quarterback  and blame it on the rival school we went  to his house and had over a hundred  rolls of toilet paper i'm telling you  this man's house was covered from top to  bottom in toilet paper we wrote on the  driveway 10 days cls cls was the rival  school that the football team was  playing in 10 days quarterback wakes up  sees his house destroyed immediately the  schools were both notified bible schools  coaches questioned their team who  obviously had no idea what happened our  school was pissed the football team  ended up playing them and beating them  by 60 points and it's funny we had girls  that were dating football players and  they still never got caught funny thing  is though that quarterback is actually  in the nfl today comment below your  guess on who it is